okay but i become leader i've never
heard about this right because the fbi
comes and just provides it to a select
few people on intel
so i asked for a briefing speaker
speaker pelosi comes and has this
briefing with me
what i know with what the fbi told me he
should never be on intel
and pelosi reappointed intel
i don't understand this did you have you
said this to her
yes but this is worse i brought a motion
to the floor
to remove him from intel put another
democrat on
the democrats all defended they don't
even have the briefing from the fbi but
they defended him having gone
and think about this he cannot get a
security clearance in the private sector
but they voted to let him have the
security clearance of american secrets
but this is our challenge china has
spent their time
studying america in every aspect from
stealing from us
from growth of food and others but they
also watched how we fought war
okay they watched desert storm they
watched it
america can move an aircraft carrier 250
miles away from anybody
and come in and bomb you right so what
they spend their time on
building aircraft carriers now but they
spent their time on building a missile
to sink an aircraft carrier
they watch our men and women the troops
don't fight by just getting on land they
fight by space
so you spend a lot of time in space do
you know
the other day china sent three
astronauts to space
did they go to the international space
station
they went to the chinese space station
they don't play with the rest of the
world
do you know china has landed on the moon
on the back side of the moon
the dark side of the boat it's hard to
land there we haven't landed there
china realizes our aircraft carriers so
what did they do
they built islands what'd they do when
barack obama
obama asked him about him we won't
weaponize him she said that
but what did he do he weaponized him to
push us further away
the only time our aircraft carriers in
recent history
were not in the strait there was during
covent
now can we win
the answer is yes the answer is yes is
there a window in opportunity just like
you started with ken
california can we win here i just
created eight
pillars to china based upon coven if
there's any moment in time to wake up
to study right for the rest of the world
to unite
once china found they had covered what
they do they stopped flights
not international flights domestic
flights
then they dominated the world health
organization to lie to the rest of the
world
they hoarded ppe
then as it went forward and the rest of
the world had it what did they do
well they controlled so much mechanism
what they built when
when france needed ppe even though they
sent
free to china china says we'll sell you
some yeah but you have to have huawei
with you
they utilize covid to get more gain
within their own technology around
the world when australia said they
wanted to study
where covet came from they went and put
sanctions tried to hurt them
economically they said the first place
their nuclear weapon could hit would be
australia they tried to intimidate what
you would do
so what america should do is actually
lead would come from strength
we should declassify the information so
the entire world should know why did
three million people in the world die
and did they need to die why did six
hundred thousand americans die
why did they why did we have to in the
process of coving
the next thing i would do is end any
gain of function
research and end it from this aspect
don't give a grant to somebody else
because you're going around saying my
government's not giving to china but
i give to you because you give to china
right can you just explain what that is
very quickly
gain a function is what you take from a
mechanism
that this didn't come from oh
somebody ate a bat right they were
trying to mechanize and change it and
they were studying it in the process so
meaning
us humans scientists are doing this this
isn't that a bat and a monkey did it and
here we are yeah and do we put funding
into it
well apparently for a long time we said
we didn't but we're finding out now we
probably did
make sure the nih which i love doesn't
provide
grants that go to north korea iran
why do we help fund our enemies okay
then why don't we do this why don't we
start looking at
who we're providing our visas to how
many times have we found
somebody from china's over here on a
visa but actually belongs to their
military how many times do we catch them
on a plane
that they are stealing documents how
many times we found out that they're
funding
the professor at the university didn't
swallow sleep with the chinese spy or
something i mean
yes why okay that's a good question i i
want to finish my eight pillars
for the rest of the world yeah when you
get to congress
republicans and democrats decide what
committees you get but there are a
couple committees that are totally
different they're decided by
groups and they're voted on right intel
committee is different than any other
committee because
members who serve on intel can only
serve for a certain amount of time but
they find out information
all the other members can't have okay
they're only selected by their leaders i
select all the republicans pelosi select
all their democrats
i am part of what is called the gang of
eight right the leaders
and the leader and the leaders in intel
we're provided information
but other people aren't right to know
what's going on
so i can't talk to you about things i
know but
on the intel committee this is all
public domain we can talk about
what we know publicly a chinese spy
and also remember senator feinstein we
found out later
the driver of more than 10 years was a
chinese spy in silicon valley
they've been in pictures together each
of it this woman a chinese spy creates a
relationship with swalwell with his and
the city council
he runs for congress she helps
she puts interns in his office do you
know how difficult it is to get on the
intel committee
when swabble was put on the intel
committee they were in the minority so
they had
fewer seats he was a sophomore getting
part on the intel committee
every single member asked me for the
intel committee there's very few
openings right
there's people highly qualified they're
just not openings form
it gets put on it's not
then the public says that the fbi came
to warn
right they weren't the leaders they had
a briefing he's kept on the intel
committee
this woman they were warning them that
there was a spy basically right
yeah i wonder how they knew she was the
spy right she wasn't just by
and then you had a mayor and other parts
think about how big your spy mechanism
must be
if you have enough money to have a spy
that cares about you when you're in the
city council
our talks about you right there's some
ran for president the only thing he has
left is a bunch of shoelaces or
something i don't know
you spent the most money on that but
anyways now you know this you put him on
you did not know
now you know as a leader okay if swawa
was in the private sector
he could not get a security clearance
because he had a relationship
with a spy but only in america can he be
given the intel
committee where he knows all the secrets
but there's 200 other democrats who are
qualified to be on that slot
and she keeps appointing i become what
is that sorry but is that also because
they know damn well that the media is
never going to call him out on it
instead it's oh trump jr had lunch with
somebody seven years ago can you believe
that right
yeah but but that's part of it right
that they can keep doing
we're not well i guess we're allowed to
talk about that on youtube now but
oh yeah you probably this is probably
never going to show well yes i'll never
show you probably
don't worry i got locals.com and it can
all go there okay
but i become leader i've never heard
about this right because the fbi comes
and just provides it to a select few
people on intel
so i asked for a briefing speaker
speaker pelosi comes and has this
briefing with me
what i know with what the fbi told me he
should never be on intel
and pelosi reappointed intel
i don't understand this did you have you
said this to her
yes but this is worse i brought a motion
to the floor
to remove him from intel put another
democrat on
the democrats all defended they don't
even have the briefing from the fbi but
they defended him having gone
and think about this he cannot get a
security clearance
in the private sector but they voted to
let him have the security clearance of
american secrets
okay so when you say that to nancy when
you say nancy we got a problem here
there's a spy etc etc nancy just me and
you in the room right now what does she
say
she handles her own members but you know
what they did too they went and removed
marjory green
for something marjorie green said before
she was of a member of congress
right as if they don't make nazi
references every two seconds these
groups
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell